a man called the most dangerous inmate  in nevada  died last week while sitting on death  row patrick mckenna was 74.  mckenna was sentenced to death for  killing his cellmate back in 1979 along  with  kidnapping sexual assault and robbery  convictions mckenna also sparked a  several days long siege back in 1979 at  the las vegas city jail  his surrender was eventually negotiated  by then channel 8 news director bob  stodall  the i-team's george knapp interviewed  mckenna in person i should say in prison  and asked about his multiple escape  attempts  we got all the way out we got all the  way out you know  all past the fence they were shooting at  us we were going under fire  as we climbed the fences we're being  shot at you can watch those stories on  mysterywire.com